hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play skinwalker now
it has been very very hard for me to get
these gameplay videos out to you guys
I'm so sorry for the delay I've just
been so working on these other great
videos but they aren't coming out
anytime soon because they take a lot of
production and planning but they're
going to be awesome and totally worth
this trip so just be patient on that one
but I am still gonna try to get games to
you so I'm recording it like midnight in
my hotel room so I hope that I'm not too
loud for my neighbors or else I'm gonna
get some police banging down my door but
anyway let's get into this game here the
following story really happened I saw it
with my own eyes maybe it didn't happen
as I saw it but more on that later okay
you can't make up your mind there kiddo
we were all going out camping me and
three friends from university you know
university of university let me
introduce my friends this is Darin I
wouldn't say that he is our group of
friends leader or actually I would this
guy cannot make his own mind
he's the one that always gets us all out
of the house and into the action he's
the first one to hit on that cute girl
at the bar he's the first one to jump
from the roof into a swimming pool that
is a terrible life decision according to
himself he was even more impulsive when
he was a kid
I can only imagine his childhood and how
often he must have broken his legs
scraped his knees and hit his head one
of those things is not like the other
still if it weren't for Darin we
wouldn't have had half the amount of fun
we have I'm sure that this story ends in
death so ah maybe not this girl is
Celeste we have known each other since
we were children we met each other when
she moved into the house next door when
I was 7 my mom told me to go show her
around the neighborhood and after that
we were inseparable for a few years
she's a nice girl although her health
isn't the best she has some kind of
heart problem which I forget the name of
this forced her to be away from school
during extended periods of time during
her childhood because of this until we
started University I was her only friend
still she never complained and I've
always seen her have a positive happy
girl next this is me I am Joe as the
name implies I'm pretty normal I don't
have any overwhelming bad qualities but
on the other hand I don't have any
overwhelming good ones either so your
normal and average I live in this
apartment a short walk from my
University this is where us for friends
usually gather before going out I'm sure
many of you Joe's out there are
amazingly awesome people and this guy is
just totally weird
this guy here looking all relaxed on my
bed is Michael with my neighbor oh he's
my neighbor living in the apartment next
door one day while I had Celeste over he
just barged in hey man your place looks
pretty nice mind if I join you for
dinner
he said that's trustworthy as you can
imagine he's pretty pushy I don't think
he realizes it himself he came over
seven times after that day after that we
somehow naturally became friends if you
say so man so how does this translate
him oh so one day Darren came with the
idea that we should go camping in the
woods with trees that look like faces or
they have faces Darren said his family
had a cabin a little bit into the forest
so camping we went it could be fun right
wrong of course me Michaels and Celeste
dislike the idea of staying in a cabin
it's a camping trip we have to sleep in
the wilderness so Darren told us about
the woods near the cabin I don't
remember much about the trip to the
cabin we joked around took a few breaks
normal stuff either way we drove up to
the cabin and left the car there we took
a short break in the cabin and set out
into the wilderness
we went pretty far in I can't say how
far in the distance exactly but it took
several hours to get where we set up
camp the first day we just screwed
around nothing abnormal happened but a
bit of a no no no no kids story kids
story with blood and - but then
dun dun Danah wait what seems like a
bright sunshiny doe I'm walking around
okay this is where the game actually
starts did you sleep well last night
I slept well with you baby mmm it was a
wonderful night's sleep okay that guy's
clearly asleep morning there or should I
say good afternoon fix to some wood for
the fire will you or screw you buddy I'm
good I shout out to gather wood for a
new fire and water to cook with wait no
one mentioned water why do I need water
where am I gonna get water
I'm guessing this where things go
horribly wrong oh no everything's done
horribly wrong I'm gonna take about ten
minutes let's see okay yes I see oh wait
what what did I get here I did not go
here okay what is that sound are demons
it doesn't sound like something you'd
hear and of course maybe cuz its demons
I really hope I'm not too loud for my
neighbours there we go
good Bucky to ward you goody goody
gumdrops what else do I do
can I get that budgie out of here a
woman suddenly I'm back the sound
stopped Oh so suspiciously he's just my
head hurts
are you the skinwalker skinwalker is
like a Native American uh tale that's
someone who can turn into animals we
sure had a blast yesterday though oh oh
no no no no no stop back your dirty
minds we sure had a blast yeah okay this
guy's still asleep maybe those go into
ten no need to go into the ten right now
so uh port water into the cooking pot we
can cook now and let's light up a fire I
should have enough of my wood to make
the fire last a while tonight light it
on fire
wait light it on fire lady
all right let's cook something up shall
we go oh let's get it let's get it
heated up in here preheat that wood by
telling it it's pretty and then slide
your pot right on what
later that evening oh isn't this nice
while sitting around the fire can I move
down okay can move hey dude
what the hell is up with this fog every
time I've been here before that has
never been any fog that couldn't
possibly mean some demons it's time to
go to sleep soon we're all out of booze
guess we have to go back to town
tomorrow I'm not looking forward to that
four-hour Trek maybe we shouldn't have
gone so deep in haha yeah maybe maybe
not
hey I can't get to the girl hey y-you
guys cock-blocking me I want it there we
go
it's really chilly outside for being in
the middle of summer hey anyone else
hear that sound ah the sound of demons
yeah now that you mention it what is
that sounds like something mentally
mentally is that even a word are you
stupid
shut up a-hole it's a word if I say so
okay I'm guessing I'm gonna be the one
that's sent out to investigate it
stopped
maybe it was some kind of machine who
the hell would go out hours from the
nearest civilization in the middle of
the night I shall revving up some kind
of weird machine who gives a [ __ ] it's
probably someone using a chainsaw or
something that's also not good let's go
to sleep I'm tired while someone's
revving up a chainsaw are you ready for
[ __ ] list ready for big I'm sure that
was no chainsaw I wonder what it was
okay
what was it sleepiness soon to overtook
everyone what the hell what the hell but
something woke you up a few hours later
in your half wake state you stumbled
outside the tent oh why why he
oh the fires about out Darren Michael
Celeste is that you what you mean they
weren't in the tent
the mist is even thicker than before I
can't see much maybe because it's also
night um I guess this is the part where
I wander out into the woods okay here we
go
hello
I may have not have mentioned it but I
really don't like camping I really don't
like camping now for the sake of I think
there are monsters in the woods but
mostly for the sake them I just don't
like camping
what is that Sam I see a shadow up there
I tried to I'm trying not to read aloud
from our neighbors
I see a shadow up there is that you
Celeste Celeste is that you Michael
cuz it's dark and I can't see you say
something will you who are you okey OOP
don't don't get either whoa stop right
here I have a knife looks cool screw you
so harder oh my god run away you dick
the hell is that mumbling muncher I'm
going back to the tent hey no I want to
see what it was don't you can't do that
not see what it is I want to see what it
is I'm going the other way
you can't stop me oh I'm going back to
the tent
coz I'm a big baby I'm a big whiny baby
oh baby want to run back to his fringe
hey wake up there's something outside
the tent it's dark and scary in well I'm
sure there is lots of squirrels and [ __ ]
go back to sleep
haze Michael here mmm here why wouldn't
I be I don't know the thing outside
looked like you it was probably some
animal I don't think we have to worry
about a fox or whatever take it easy and
go back to sleep
well alright maybe it was just some
animal okay never mind
but those sounds and the shape was
humanoid a few minutes later oh this is
gonna be good oh [ __ ] that okay drop it
whoever that is I want to go to sleep
already
it wasn't me me neither that didn't
sound like any of our voices okay should
we go outside and look what if it's some
crazy psycho with an axe all the more
reason to check it out it's not like the
tented some kind of impenetrable
fortress true that seriously if that was
one of you guys tell me right now this
aint funny no more what no okay everyone
get out together and check it out I
ain't going alone
good idea most people in horror movies
like this don't do that what are you
doing what the heck is that
whoa okay there's a dead something
someone was definitely here
shi-it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] calm down Celeste
we are four against one here it'll be
fine
what if they do got some kind of weapon
with him I mean he killed this little
critter didn't eat Michael's right we
got to get the hell out of here
we can't just up and leave it's the
middle of the night what about our stuff
sweep our stuff I'm not staying here
another minute fine we'll leave but at
least bring the flashlight in some food
while some guy with some sense here I
think you're overreacting though we
haven't seen anyone still someone or
something left this dead creature here
we can't exactly go back to sleep no
worries I guess you're right I'll go get
the flashlight everyone bring some stuff
you think we might need a couple of
minutes later all right let's go Oh it's
like oh it's like an RPG is real they
all went inside me what is that anyway
is that like a squirrel it seems too big
to be an actual squirrel but okay
whatever let's
go I know we'll meet up with that thing
okay shift to run faster which is
something I haven't seen since uh the
witch's house
it's show dark at least it's still
summer it's not pitch-black
this fog is really annoying no going
back to the cabin wait I guess that's
the plan
he's probably not a good plan maybe you
should just get the hell out
I heard the heads what is that
okay I gotta mention this really this
isn't a creepy as the other hotel room
I've been in but recording these games
in an unfamiliar location is kind of
strange to me a while later it became
obvious Darren had no idea where we were
going he was swearing and looking all
around we have been walking for an
awfully long time now are you sure we're
on the right path Darren I've walked
this path hundred the times were on the
right path I don't recognize anything
from when we were walking to camp though
I said were on the wrong path but as
time went on it became obvious that
Darren had no idea where we were wasn't
that way you just said Darren couldn't
find the path maybe it was the fog maybe
the darkness maybe something else
either way we were lost I kept looking
behind me I was having that feeling
where you think someone is watching or
stalking you I nearly tripped over
Celeste when she fell help Celeste up no
no I'm actually gonna do no no she took
her head and got to her feet the ground
was getting muddy
it was giving even Monsieur she was so
les can pick herself up he doesn't need
my help
if not for the flashlight I wouldn't
have any of you who she was was I
supposed to mean I recognized a tree
we're getting to the cabin is it the
three with the face on it cuz he told
you where it was again I had the feeling
that something was watching me my gut
was streaming that something was
somewhere was wrong I realized the sound
was from earlier was back softer but
still present I started looking around
panicking did a head count or marabou
accurately a silhouette count me Celeste
walking beside me Darren in the lead
Michael to the left who the heck was a
guy with a muggle i quickened my pace
why didn't you tell them about it I
thought about shouting out but was
worried if I did maybe the thing would
turn around and junk Michael
but no tell Michael about the thing
never mind I didn't know what to do I
ran my fingers on a knife I brought from
camp then the cabin appeared out of
nowhere the mist was just starting to
disintegrate around us it was easier to
make out everyone who everyone was now I
looked at the thing next to Michael
shoot you look sad
oh no the thing next to me lead in front
of me I shouldn't read her screams but
my body was clenching up for no reason
the thing turned and walked into the
mist what the hell I should've helped us
up I caught up with the others as they
entered the cabin practically in tears
they couldn't find the car and were
arguing about where we put it I told
them I saw obviously they didn't believe
me
still everyone hurried inside and locked
the door thump thump thump oh God
he followed us here you really want
something from us
what the hell does he want with us
someone get the shotgun what would I get
the shotgun [ __ ] okay
shoot he will kill us shoot him good
idea do that go oh yeah actually shot no
joke nobody said a word for what felt
like an hour finally Michael slowly
opened walked towards the door and
opened it but they saw sent them all in
to show it was Joe I was Joe the door
was out happy father
then everyone realize they'd made a
mistake jobs at the door with this but
I'm Joe bad and I didn't help Celeste up
I should have helped her up I didn't
help her up no I don't know can I oh it
just ends Oh No there was no save system
aah
god damn it I didn't do it
oh man it's like midnight - I gotta get
to bed fudged nutters it's I gotta get
up early tomorrow I was oh why didn't I
help Celeste up okay I'm gonna revisit
this but I'm gonna start at the point
where it cuz this is really interesting
it's really interesting I really like it
um so let me know in the comments below
I don't have time to go back through
everything again and finish it like I
normally would because it literally is
it's after midnight now and I got to get
up at 6:00 um in order to go to a
YouTube thing I'm actually getting some
training at YouTube space so it's gonna
be really cool but I gotta get up early
to prep for that and go to it so I'm
sorry I didn't get far into it now I
apologize how did you how did that
happen how did that the real Joe and
what and I was Joe I was Joe what
happened I don't know I was having fun
with that so anyway um I'll revisit this
again later
it's very story heavy but I think that's
okay because I actually like this story
so it's pretty cool so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye